وعندما نتحدث عن العلا نتحدث عن تاريخ قصص
وروايات جميله الجميع يحب ويريد ان يسمعه
وما افضل من السيد تامر عبد الكريم الراوي
والمرشد السياحي ليطلعنا عليها يحدثنا عن
تاريخ العلا بشكل عام واجمل القصص
المتعلقه بها يسعد
هالصباحكم جميعا والله يحييكم في هذا
اليوم الجميل
اليوم عندما نحكي عن العلا نحكي عن بلد
العشاق لماذا سميت بلد العشاق
بالمقام الاول الاولى عشاق عشاق الطبيعه
عشاق الجمال للارض كذلك همم مره على العلا
مجموعه من الشعراء العشاق زي جميل بثينه
العزه وقيل ان قيس مجنون ليلى
من هنا وجميل عائشه هنا ههه
يا استاذ تامر لماذا سميت العلاقه
من وادي القرى من شعب النعام من دادان كل
هذه اسماء كانت للعلا
مؤخرا جاء اسم العلا من نخل عاليات عند
احد العيون اللي يعني المهلق كان يتواعد
عندها الركبان هذه العين في لقاءاتهم
فانتقابل عند العاليات او العلا كانت
بالالف المقصوره الى ان اصبح المسمى
العلاج
اذا مسميات عده للعلا الى ان وصل الى اسمه
العلا استاذ تامر شرح لنا سبب تسميه علا
بهذا الاسم طب يا استاذ تامر دايما احنا
اللي عايشين مثلا في مناطق خارج السعوديه
لغير السعوديين وحتى ايضا من داخل
السعوديه لمن لم يظهر العلا ماذا تقول في
وصف العلا
طيب
الجبال طبعا العلا مدينه التاريخ والاثار
كما سماها اسمه سيدي ولي العهد هي المتحف
المفتوح في البوابه الشماليه في المملكه
فالعلا تاريخ بجمالها بجمال جمالها بجمال
هظابها بنخيلها وكذلك لا ننسى الانسان
الموجود
[موسيقى]
وخصوصا نحن قاعدين في جلسه بدويه في قلب
رمال الصحراء بين جبال العلاقه طبعا قامت
بشكر الرئيس التكافل الاجتماعي نجد من
الجميع
التعايش مع الواقع اللي هم موجودين فيه
نقول دائما الانسان
وهذا بالضبط
[موسيقى]
طيب السؤال الاخير اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
العلا نتحدث عن حضارات قامت ثقافه وادب
وايضا تعليم ماذا نقول في ذلك
واستمر بها طبعا دادان والحيوان الى
الانباط الى وجودنا في الاصل هذه العلا لم
تغيب عنها شمس الحضاره ذكرت التعليمه
التعليمي مميز في العلا التعليم القديم
جدا قدم التاريخ في العلا لا ننسى ان
العلا فيها تقريبا ثالث مدرسه في المملكه
مملكتنا الحبيبه التعليم كان قديما في
الكتاتيب يعني ذكر او رواه والاهالي انه
عام 1319 كان هناك في البيوت الى ان اصبحت
الى المدرسه نظامها جزيلا شكرا على وجودك
معنا استاذ تامر عبد الكريم الراوي الشمس
شكرا